this lush green rice buddy has provided
a livelihood for generations of farmers
but recently they've watched helplessly
as floods transformed their farm lines
into new fishing grounds those who
cannot cope are forced to leave Muhammad
Ali who is trying to salvage what he can
of his melody and sugar at least for the
next meal the rest he says is lost no
one in my village is spared by this
unfolding disaster this is the second
consecutive year we experienced in this
I've already lost 10 farms with rice
beans ground nuts and so gone his loss
is echoed in villages lining Nigeria's
coast and river valleys this year areas
that account for 80% of the country's
agricultural production Nigerians have
been warned to expect more flooding
nationwide raising fears of possible
food shortages as crops are washing away
the country was recently listed among 41
countries that require food aid partly
because of severe weather conditions and
because government has banned food
importation through its land borders
many families may struggle to feed
themselves the governor of the state
says the state government is struggling
to help over 100,000 people over 70,000
hectares of farmland gone this year also
similar figures but what is interesting
this year for us is the new places that
have not been traditionally under
floating and what we could only do now
is to support those people that have
lost their towns to put them in shelters
and try to see how we can feed them but
they after everything the farmland that
is lost the crops that were lost and the
houses that were lost we don't have that
strength to do to help people for many
years the annual rainfall in this region
is 800 millimeters but people have seen
the level exceeding 1,000 millimeters in
the past few years in the northern part
we have so much of this floods during
the rainy season our farmers cannot
cultivate in the dry season where I get
is so much of dryness and from the
southern part we also have so much of
flood the floods and droughts are partly
to blame for fighting between farmers
and cattle herders hundreds have been
killed in the region in the battle for
land and water but for fishermen these
are good times with village streets and
roads becoming new fishing grounds even
temporarily there is a catch to be made
how many trees al Jazeera
oh you Nigeria